my throat these days. Okay, so now we are going. All right, so, as with all the others, please introduce yourself.
Steve Lawson, today's date is December 15th, 2011, we're in a conference room at the Valley Library.
Okay, Steve, so today we're going to do something a little different from past
sessions. What we're going to do is essentially, this goes through a list of names of people that
either worked at the Institute or were affiliated with some way of asking you to sort of give your
recollections as to rules they played an institute and any sorts of memorable interactions you had with them.
Okay, and a lot of these folks, if you've always touched on over the course of our talk,
are you ready? So the first one is Zelda Herman. Zelda Herman joined the Institute. I believe in the
late 1970s he had had an academic position at Stanford University and had come up
from New York City prior to that and worked very closely with Linus Pawn on theoretical problems
in structural chemistry to the best of my recollection early on. He also had a strong background
in statistics so he helped people at the Institute with biostatistical analyses and I believe
participated in the analysis of some of the data that you and Cameron was generating
cancer mortality data with vitamin C and cancer studies in Scotland.
In the mid to late 1980s Linus Pawn came up with an idea for a novel fabrication technique
for superconductive material that was different from the prevailing ceramic
work that many people were doing and Pawn approached Zellik and myself to set up a laboratory
in Stanford Industrial Park to carry out some experiments to confirm his ideas about the
way that this material could be fabricated that would be in support of his patent application.
So Zellik and I sat about buying a furnace and blowtorch and we had a facility already at
Porter Drive and we were just using a few rooms in this facility and Zellik came up with an
ingenious way to collect this material which essentially consisted of very thin
tin fibrils that were clad in borosilicate glass and the glass surrounded the tin
at the point of maximum temperature over a furnace helped a course by a blowtorch so we needed
to collect these long strands of tin encased in glass and Zellik came up with a terrific idea which
was kind of a bicycle frame upside down mounted on a wood platform and then we could there weren't
tires on the rims there were just bare rims and the idea was that we could make this a continuous
operation one person would be at the furnace wielding blowtorch melting the glass at a very
steady rate very controlled very steady very exact precise operation and then as that glass
was melted and the tin was melted it would be collected onto the back tire of this bicycle frame
and then somebody the other person Zellik or myself would be there threading the glass onto the
wire rim of the bicycle and then engaging the pedal mechanism to collect the glass on the
bicycle wire rim and it worked quite well and Zellik and I maintained a notebook according to
Linus Plunk standards that was countersigned by a music a Milser Krakhandel either at the end
of every day or at the end of every week so that a third party uninvolved with the experimental work
could testify that they had read it and understood it and I got to know Zellik pretty well through
that whole process and of course he'd been at the institute a very long time his tenure there
almost exactly coincided with mine I can't recall if I got there a little before him or
will after him but I know that he arrived in the late 1970s mid to late 1970s and I got to know
him very well over the years and really respected and admired and liked him as a person I think he had
the desire to devote his career to this relationship scientific relationship with Linus Pauling
and I think that Linus Pauling dependent on him very greatly for this work that he himself might
have not had time to do and Zellik was able to talk with Linus Pauling about some of these
more abstract problems and theoretical chemistry that the rest of us at the institute probably
were not able to converse easily with Linus Pauling about Zellik when the institute was wrapping
up its activities in Palo Alto and I have to say that Zellik was very important in that whole
operation he had become the institute's safety officer over time so he worked very carefully
and closely with Palo Alto fire department with our hazardous materials plan which we didn't really
have prior to Zellik taking that position and he also helped me a lot by kind of serving as my
sorry get when I was away from the institute at that time I was chief executive officer and when I
was gone Zellik very kindly and effectively offered to stand in for me and solve problems as
they arose at the institute in my absence which was he did a terrific job of that as well
and Zellik also participated very closely in the analysis of the closure of the institute
hiring the moving firm disposal furniture laboratory equipment chemicals and so forth so
he was he was involved in that whole process very very thoroughly on a day-to-day basis in
the last years of the institute the institute was not in a position to secure employment
of LPISM employees at Oregon State University so there have been a number of visits by Oregon State
University faculty and administrators to the Palo Alto facility to talk with our scientists there
about whether or not they were interested in coming to to Corvallis to become part of Oregon State
University and the Linus Plines Institute and whether it would be a good fit for those candidates
and Oregon State University academic units so Oregon State University ended up not offering
a position to Zellik to the best of my recollection and after that he did some work I believe for
Stanford and some other faculty in the Bay area and also did some teaching in the Palo Alto
public school system I believe and maybe elsewhere I was I was not involved in compiling or editing
or managing that project but they did an outstanding job Zellik is very very meticulous he has a
very keen eye for detail he'd make a good editor and he was he was driven to make sure that this
collected papers to Linus Paul in the inventory of these papers was as thorough and complete as
possible so he worked very closely with Dorothy on that project and of course Linus Pauling as
well because Pauling himself had to provide some reprints of some papers that were quite old and
and weren't part of the Linus Plines Institute of Science and Medicine inventory or library so that
was a really terrific project that Zellik and Dorothy did jointly and then of course that was sort
of the nucleus for a project that was then taken up by special collections here at Oregon State
University and then expanded to this five volume set that was recently published.
Dorothy was a terrific person she had been at the institute I believe nearly from its inception
and she worked ostensibly as Linus Pauling secretary but that term doesn't really do justice to
the comprehensive nature for duties and responsibilities she assisted Linus Pauling and all his
travel arrangements managed his calendar for appearances prepared his manuscripts to be submitted
for publication of different journals managed his correspondence and also transcribed his numerous
dictaphone dictation belts so she played a very very important role in Linus Pauling's life keeping
everything straight and organized and really providing personal and secretary on managerial
assistance to him and I think that she was invaluable I don't think he could have managed without
Dorothy Monroe Dorothy was an interesting person she was not very extroverted maybe a little skeptical
but I really I really enjoyed her we had some good laughs and mainly our humor was based on
sort of cynical takes on institute affairs but she when she found something funny she was
really prone to some hilarity but it took a bit to get over that threshold sometimes Richard Hicks
Richard Hicks had been at the institute when I joined he was a former stockbroker or
administrator with I believe Merrill Lynch so correct I have to check on that it was big stock
brokerage and they had a big office in San Francisco and Richard Hicks first wife had died of cancer
and that had stimulated his interest in what Pauling called orthomolecular medicine the prevention
and treatment of disease with micronutrients in particular vitamin C and Rick joined the institute
probably in the mid 1970s when art Robinson and Linus Pauling and the board probably became convinced
that we needed some managerial experience and direction at the helm of our fundraising efforts
which at that time included contact with foundations philanthropists large donors people interested
in Linus Pauling's work as well as a mailing list that provided a base for solicitation for
the institute so Rick kind of organized and managed all that and also was very engaged in certain
travels with Linus Pauling that had a fundraising aspect so he he traveled with Linus Pauling quite
often on the 70s and 80s he did you know there have been a couple of conflicts at the institute
one involved Pauling Hicks and art Robinson which led to art Robinson's departure and art I believe
at some point wanted to fire or tried to fire Rick Hicks and he was prohibited from doing that
expressly by the board and Linus Pauling which led of course to this administrative conflict that
led to arts departure there are other reasons for that of course but that was one element of that
conflict that arose in the late 1970s and then when Emile Zucacondo became president director of
the institute after Robinson's departure Rick Hicks worked very very closely with Emile over the
years to try to find financial funding for the institute's research activities and our educational
activities as well so the two of them worked extremely closely and then of course with Linus Pauling
as his schedule permitted to seek out cultivate and find to find and cultivate donors who could
support some of our projects at the institute and then when the institute was reorganized
after Emile's retirement Rick decided since I think partly I don't want to put words in his
mouth but I think he decided partly because of his long close association with Emile
that the time had come for him to to resign as well and as he resigned from the Linus Pauling
Institute of Science and Medicine he was offered a position on the board so we became a board member
of the board of trustees of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine and then also had
a position with Emile's embryonic institute institute for molecular medical sciences which was as
I discussed previously sub leasing space from us in the same facility at 440 page mail road
as did he retire after that job? Do you know where you should supply something else?
Well institute and molecular medical sciences to the best of my knowledge never really
reach critical mass. They had a few employees early on and then when the zoning change finally
kicked in and that building that they were located on a schedule for demolition I think that was
the effective end of the of that organization so I don't know whether Rick continued any
active role with IMMS after it was lost its physical existence there at 440 page mail road
but Rick has remained a big advocate and friend of the Linus Pauling Institute over all these
years and I talk with him reasonably often on the phone and he comes to visit us in Corvallis
during big events like the 10th anniversary party and so forth. He couldn't make it to the grand
opening of the Linus Pauling Science Center but he sent flowers and he's always been a good friend
of the Linus Pauling Institute. Well Emile is quite elderly now and I think he had
some kind of adjunct position at Stanford in one of their academic departments that probably
overlapped the existence of IMMS but I don't know if he retains any courtesy or adjunct appointment
at Stanford any longer. I think so he's the founding editor of course of the Journal of Molecular
Evolution which is one of the leading journals in that field and I think he has retired as editor
of that journal he probably remains on the editorial board but I know his duties with respect to
that journal have diminished quite a lot as well so he may have an emeritus position with the journal
at this point. Rexie Jerry Walla joined the institute I believe from Johns Hopkins
in the early 1980s I believe to head the laboratory of viral carcinogenesis and at that time
Emile's plan for the institute was to expand along the lines of the Salk Institute in
Mojolla kind of important projects in orthomolecular medicine and molecular biology
and Rexie's work was an example of the work in molecular biology in particular. He was
interested in Herpes virus type 2 and fragments of Herpes virus type 2 DNA that could transform
normal cells and make them tumorogenic. So he had a big program that was involved in that research
and I collaborated with him on several projects there was a donor named Robert Saven
in Long Island who developed some very interesting ideas about phytoc acid and cancer. Phytoc acid
is an antioxidant that you find in grains and seeds and it protects the germplasm material
in seeds from oxidative damage before germination and he had approached
either Linus Polymer and Emile Zucaconda with some of these ideas and then I started talking
with him about his ideas and we set up kind of a small experimental research program
to carry out some cell culture experiments and Rexie and I started directly collaborating at that
time and also we worked together on using 2D gel technology to profile proteins in rat cells that
had been transfected with these Herpes virus DNA fragments. So my developed quite a lot of experience
and skill at producing these protein profiles and Rexie was very interested in that to find out
how gene activity and protein expression changed as a result of neoplastic transformation in these
rat cells. So I collaborated with Rexie on a number of different projects over time and then of
course mid to late 1980s as AIDS was becoming kind of a public health crisis in the San Francisco
Bay area in New York and some other places. There was interest in finding out once HIV had been
identified as the causal factor there, the etiologic agent in developing arcane AIDS,
there was interest in finding out whether or not vitamin C might have any effect on protecting
people from dysvirus or have any beneficial effect in people that were already infected with a virus.
So in collaboration with Linus Pauling and Steve Herike who had been recruited to work in
Rexie's group they published a paper on PNAS in the late 1980s showing that in cell cultures
to human T lymphocytes infected with HIV did not develop certain pathological characteristics
when they were grown in physiologically relevant concentrations of vitamin C and vitamin C also
inhibited replication of the virus which could be assayed with a number of different techniques.
So the conclusion in that paper that I remember correctly was that there may be a combinatorial
approach to treating AIDS that would involve AZT which protects uninfected cells from getting infected
by HIV combined with vitamin C which would inhibit viral replication. So you're inhibiting viral
replication and protecting uninfected cells and maybe this would be a good therapeutic strategy
for AIDS patients. And that resulted in not any so far as I can remember direct collaboration with
physicians at San Francisco General which of course had ward 86 which was a major AIDS treatment
facility in the United States but people from ward 86 Paul Bulberding and Don Abrams came to the
institute to give seminars on some of their experience in treating AIDS patients and of course a
lot of AIDS patients in San Francisco were self-medicating with high dose vitamin C as well and the
physicians at San Francisco General had some anecdotal evidence that seemed to support some value
of vitamin C in this role. Rex seat was not offered a job by Oregon State University and I
believe he took a job with it's a research organization. He had some grants from Pacific Medical
Center I believe in San Francisco that were sustaining his research activities and they think
they were transferred to California Pacific. I'd have to think about the name of the facility but
it's a medical research facility in San Jose and he took a job with them and then most recently I
believe he has joined Dr. Rath's research activity which is located in Santa Clara County or
Santa Clara, California. So I think that's where he works currently. I'd love to have Constance
Chau. Constance Chau had been at the institute for a very long time she again I believe was there
when I joined in 1977. She was a chemist who had been hired to do a lot of work with vitamin C
and of course Linus Pond was very interested in biochemical attributes of vitamin C in the body and
there had been a lot of red flags about high dose vitamin C whether it could destroy vitamin B12
whether it would cause kidney stones excuse me kidney stones whether it would leach minerals or
amino acids from the body or interfere with amino acid metabolism. So there have been a number of
concerns about vitamin C for a long time and Connie Chau in collaboration with Linus Pond and she
had a small staff to help her as well was addressing a lot of these concerns about high dose vitamin C
and she was also doing a lot of she was directing a lot of work that was geared towards understanding
at some level some of the pharmacokinetics of vitamin C in other words if people take a certain
oral dose of vitamin C how much shows up in the urine and what is the result in blood concentration.
So she was doing studies like that and also trying to get at the role of vitamin C as an anti-cancer
agent. So in the 1980s as Linus Pond's ideas about the anti-cancer role of vitamin C developed I
mean initially it was post-resistance to vitamin C was the main anti-cancer theme for vitamin C
as hypothesized by you and Cameron and Linus Pond and then over time they started to develop some
new ideas which was to involve direct cytotoxicity of vitamin C or metabolites of vitamin C or degradation
products of vitamin C. So vitamin C would get when it gets ingested in the body can transform into
other chemical moieties that have different attributes and part of Connie Chau's research program was
to identify some of these breakdown products and metabolites of vitamin C and to find out whether
they had any anti-cancer effect in cell culture studies and in small animal studies and she was
quite successful in this and published a number of papers showing that degradation products of
vitamin C seemed to possess strong anti-cancer activity and she also did some work I believe
that was stimulated by reports from Japanese researchers Morshiga and Marata that
vitamin C combined with a copper tripeptide had very interesting anti-cancer effects and of course
the basis for that involves free radical chemistry so that's something that bit Connie Chau was
pursuing as well. She was at the institute until we closed our doors
in Palo Alto and then she effectively retired. I want to ask about if you're at Marata and if you can
once you get involved. They were non-resident fellows of the institute there had been a number
of non-resident fellows appointed over the years so far as I can recall they never carried out
any experimental work at the institute's facilities either in the mental park of Palo Alto
but they had longstanding and far-ranging discussions with Linus Pauling about the effect of
vitamin C in viral infection and cancer and in particular I think their earliest work had to do with
preventing transfusion associated viral hepatitis in hospital patients at their hospital in Japan
and they showed that by giving vitamin C to transfuse patients they were able to decrease the
incidence of transfusion associated hepatitis to almost negligible levels and of course that
intrigue Linus Pauling greatly and then they also developed an interest in vitamin C in cancer
which involved this copper tripeptide and carried out animal experiments, soul culture experiments
and even some surprisingly clinical work with copper tripeptide and high dose vitamin C typically
given intravenously and they published a number of papers and monographs.
Yeah, Morishega and Morata has remained close to the institute. He's been a supporter of the
institute for many years even since we moved here to Corvallis. Morishega, I'm not sure what's
become of him. I don't know what his current status is. I don't know if he's retired. If he has
a job someplace or if he's still writing and carrying out any work in that area but I know
in the late 80s and early 90s perhaps he did become increasingly interested in the beta-glucan
fraction of Mataki mushroom in particular but that glucan fraction is also present in other
mushroom varieties and I think he had done some work in soul culture and maybe animal experiments
to show that not only did it have immunostimulatory properties but seemed to have anti-cancer
properties as well and there's quite a big literature on that mushroom extracts and their
anti-cancer effect but as far as I can recall none of that took place at the Linus Pong Institute
it was solely focused on vitamin C at that time. They did they did they did yeah yeah and I think
that one or more of them maybe Morishega also spent some time with colleagues at Stanford University
at that time too but I can't really recall the details of those associations.
How about William A. Berth? William A. Berth had come to the institute from SRI which at that time
was known as Stanford Research. Stanford Research SRI industrial let me think.
Well anyway it had been originally affiliated with Stanford University and then I think
became an independent entity which is interestingly where I learned to do cell culture in the 1980s when
I set up our first cell culture facility at the facility in Memel Park. A. Berth was a physicist or
is a physicist who developed the Volcano Source Field Identization Mass Spectrometer that was used
in Pauling and Robinson's Metabolite Profiling Program so he was constantly developing that trying
to improve its parameters and improve the technology and that was his primary role at the institute.
He was also a really great ping pong player. We played ping pong quite often at noon and he invariably
beat me. So he designed instruments then? He did he designed instruments and worked on their
technical evolution and it was always a bit of a I won't say conflict but there's always some stress
there between instrument design and development and the biologists or biochemists who actually want
to use the instrumentation to gain data and then analyze data. And part of the problem with that
with that relationship is that the physicists always want to improve the technology. The biologists
want the technology to get to a certain acceptable level and then keep it constant and then run
lots of samples because if you keep changing the technology over time then the sample analysis
changes over time too and it makes it very difficult from a biological perspective to understand
what's going on with some of these things so it was interesting.
Well metabolic profiling I think what Robinson and Pauling and I can't claim to be an expert in this
area but I think what they were doing and what they had proposed at that time was really cutting
edge technology and cutting edge science and I believe that there's a lot of interest in that now
that may use slightly different technologies but nevertheless has the same goal of understanding
preventative medicine because the idea there was to try to detect very subtle biochemical changes
that would be reflected in body fluids such as saliva or typically urine was used because it's
easy to to use experimentally that might correlate with a predisposition to particular
pathological states like cancer and also to use it as a diagnostic tool so that you would for instance
take samples from hundreds of people diagnosed with a specific disease like muscular dystrophy
or multiple sclerosis or a particular type of cancer or even old people versus young people
or gender or something like that and then look for clues in the metabolic profile run through
this mass spectrometer that might correlate with that particular condition and for instance if you
found in a population of people with this particular type of cancer a representative or a set of
representative peaks on a mass spectrogram that correlated with that condition and you did not find
those peaks in normal healthy people then ostensibly you could use this to check someone's health
over time to see whether or not those substances represented by those peaks in the disease state
are starting to amplify in the healthy person's profile over time and if they are then you could
suppose that there are biochemical events taking place in that person that are leading to cancer
and if you had that knowledge very very early in the disease process the idea would be that you could
implement therapy much sooner and probably have a better therapeutic outcome so that kind of
thinking I think was was extraordinarily prescient and way way ahead of its time yeah memory series
it started with the specific brain work yeah yeah but the metabolic profile I mean they had at one
point I think under art Robinson's direction the idea was to build up a repository of urine samples
or blood samples from the inates collected through the VA hospital and other hospitals around
California and then these samples would be held at minus 80 degrees centigrade for decades and
then you would check on these people much later in life to find out what had happened to them
if they developed certain diseases and then go back and look at these samples to find out if
nor any clues or how these samples or how subsequent samples might have changed to give clues to
the progression of these particular diseases so I think it was a very very interesting program
that would eventually stop because of funding issues and there were some technical issues as well
for example the volcano source which is where the ionization of these volatile components took place
tended to erode and also material would would accumulate on this that could contaminate subsequent
sample analysis so there were some practical problems with how do you clean this cone between
samples and the life span of the cone and and other issues as well and some of those things are
what Bill Abarth and his people that took over that project after he left work on for years
how about Alan Sheets? Alan Sheets was at the institute when I arrived he was working in
biochemistry he was operating and developing gas chromatography and instrumentation
to do this kind of work the metabolite profiling work using not just human samples but with a focus
I think in the early days on rodent samples so analyzing rodent urine mouse urine typically using
gas chromatography so he was an expert in gas chromatography and worked very closely with
Bill Abarth as well as Art Robinson and then we developed a friendship and he I think we like
each other and he wanted me to get more involved in some of the work that he was doing in the laboratory
so Alan and I set up some experiments for you and Cameron to check and maybe I talked about this
before Cameron was very concerned about high dose vitamin C in people who are undergoing chemotherapy
because vitamin C can have general detoxifying capabilities and Cameron was concerned that
if chemotherapy is expected to be therapeutic for cancer patients then you don't want to
do anything to interfere with it and if high dose vitamin C interferes with specific chemotherapy
drug activity then you don't want to recommend it to people who are undergoing chemotherapy or perhaps
you want to alternate it with chemotherapy because chemotherapy is typically given in cycles
so to get at this question Alan and I set up a fishtoxicology experiment using fingering trout
and we reconstituted distilled water with there's a lot of literature in fishtoxicology and how to
make experimental aquariums per fish and so we followed that literature and we set up some
experiments to look at the combination of methotrexate and other chemotherapy drugs alone and
in combination with vitamin C on swimming behavior in the fish because when fish aren't feeling good
they stop swimming so there were ways to actually monitor the movement of the fish in the tanks
and that was one of the last experiments I did with Alan and then Alan was also very
he was very closely involved in the move because I think his father had worked as a mover,
had a moving company in Idaho so Alan was had experience in moving and we handled the move
ourselves from the mental park facility to the Page Mill Avenue facility in Palo Alto back in the winter
1980-1981 and Alan really took a major responsibility for that and coordinated that move and also
I think worked pretty closely with Emilio Zucicondo in design and setup of the new laboratory facility
at 440 Page Mill Road because we were moving into what had been essentially a battery factory
I believe and it needed to be reconfigured for for our work and I think Alan played an important role
in that as well and then eventually he retired he became I think less interested in biochemistry and
more interested in what would it be called physical therapy because his daughter had been born with
a genetic defect that caused muscle problems so she didn't have very graceful gate and Alan
became very interested in physical therapy that might help his daughter become sort of have a more
normal gate and more normal body actions so he eventually adopted that as a new career
what got done him was a retired physician who I think had spent most of his career in Tennessee
at the VA hospital memory service me and then had worked at Jackson Laboratory in Maine for quite a
long time I can't remember exactly why he came to the institute but this was in the I believe
the early 1980s he came and set up a program to look at the effect of afflatoxin toxicity on
guinea pigs and whether that could they could be protected or rescued from afflatoxin toxicity
with vitamin C oh excuse me initially it was not afflatoxin it was beta amenopopryonitrile which
is a compound that exists in the grass pee which is a lagoon that people in India and other places
consume and it has the unfortunate characteristic of causing leg paralysis so when you consume
the grass pee products made from the grass pee over a long period of time you become very vulnerable
to irreversible leg paralysis so it affects the central nervous system and nervous tissue
so when you see a lot of the you know long long ago when you see these kind of archetypal photos
of beggars and calcutta and so forth and sometimes they'd be pulling themselves along on little
platforms with wheels with sticks and a lot of those people had succumbed to neural atherism and
of course when somebody develops neural atherism they can't work any longer and at least in India
in those days they were reduced to begging in the street for for money to to sustain themselves
so it was a big public health problem in some regions of the world because
the grass pee provided nutrition it's a lagoon so it had some nutritional value and it grows
like a weed so it doesn't really require any special agricultural practices it can grow and
drought or you know lots of water so it's something that's very available to people and they don't
know about the the downside of consuming this over a long period of time so what got done in
particular get very interested in whether or not vitamin C might inhibit the development of
neural atherism in people that are unavoidably exposed die terribly to this lagoon that contains
the neurotoxin so he set up a research program that involved guinea pigs because guinea pigs do not
synthesize vitamin C so you can control the amount of vitamin C in their bodies very carefully and
very easily and he would give these guinea pigs the toxin responsible for neural atherism and
they would develop hind leg paralysis very similar to what happens in people and men for some
reasons seem to be especially vulnerable to this and I don't know if that was checked in guinea pigs
because I think typically in those kinds of experiments you go for single gender you don't want
to house male and female guinea pigs together unless you're trying to breed guinea pigs so I don't
remember whether these were male guinea pigs or female guinea pigs but nevertheless they developed
hind leg paralysis when given this toxin however if you gave them the toxin and coadministered vitamin C
you could completely prevent paralysis or if there was paralysis it was transient so that that was
quite encouraging and also there are histopathological changes that can occur in the liver that did not
occur when the toxin was coadministered with vitamin C so vitamin C seemed to be protecting
their nervous system and liver is from pathological damage caused by exposure to this toxin
and I think what I've done him was very interested in taking this to the World Health Organization
and trying to get them to do human studies and find out whether this might be a low cost
remedy for this public health problem in regions of the world where people eat the grass
pee if you could allow them to continue eating the grass pee and give them low cost vitamin C supplements
with the advice that you know go ahead and eat this but be sure you take your vitamin C
then perhaps that would be less of a serious problem for those people
and then I think a little bit later he got interested in aflatoxin
and aflatoxin toxicity and guinea pigs and how that could be attenuated by coadministered
with vitamin C and he's back around the Institute. He did he stayed at the Institute for a very
long time retired in his wife we're very charming very very nice people and he retired probably in
I can't remember exactly when but towards the end of our 10 year there in palilato
John Levitt. John Levitt had been recruited from Johns Hopkins and may have known Rexie
Jarawal actually at Johns Hopkins. Levitt was recruited to direct our laboratory molecular
carcinogenesis which again was established by a meal with the idea of expanding the institute's
research into more molecular biological areas rather than strictly worth the molecular medicine
and John was very interested in again using this two-dimensional gel electrophoresis protein profiling
technology to understand fundamental differences between normal cells and cancer cells
in people and he discovered the mutant beta actin protein which seemed to be present in most
tumor cells that he looked at and maybe teen lymphocytes as well but never present in normal cells
so a lot of his work was geared toward understanding this mutant beta actin and also
he did some transgenic work and secured a patent with a colleague at Stanford that was commercialized
one of our rare successful commercializations of patents. I think Stanford actually led the
the commercialization effort there but nevertheless the institute benefited from royalties
from Levitt's invention there with a promoter of the mutant beta actin protein.
How about Jeffrey Bland? Jeffrey Bland was recruited to the institute back in the late 70s
from the University of Puget Sound where I think he had been a chemistry professor
and he joined the institute I think to work both on the Metabolite Profiling project but more
specifically to develop a new project which was called the Nutritional Supplement Analysis Laboratory
so the idea was to analyze nutritional supplements for their dissolution in the gastrointestinal
environment and also analyze them for purity and to find out if the label represented what
the actual ingredients were in nutritional supplements and the goal there was to
award some sort of certificate or seal kind of like the UL underwriters label or something
like that good housekeeping seal of approval two products that passed the stringent
qualifications and I think it was it was an interesting program and again way ahead of its time
I think it was so far ahead of its time that they had a very difficult time finding companies
that wanted to participate at that time they were selling their nutritional supplements very
happening and I guess didn't see the need for any kind of competitive advantage that might be
gained from this Linus Point Institute nutritional supplement analysis seal of approval
so eventually that program was disbanded
he moved on from there he also had a developing career as a public speaker and I think was very
interested in writing lecturing and set up some businesses in Washington as well
years of yorka years of yorka
did work there was primarily related to a meals interest in molecular evolution
I don't know specifically what year's these training was as a biologist or biochemist
I don't believe he was trained as a chemist but I don't know what his degree was in
but he had a very a very robust grant from the Department of Energy to analyze
allu sequences and the conservation of allu sequences in DNA and junk DNA over time
and he became after the institute's reorganization I think the assistant director of research
with the role ostensibly of helping Linus Point when Linus Point was absent or
providing input to Linus Point to make decisions about strategic decisions about research programs
at the institute and he was offered a job at Oregon State University but declined to come
north because I think his wife is a physician and had a very good practice in the San Jose area
they like living there and didn't want to come to Oregon I don't know if he was specifically
offered a position but clearly OSU was interested in recruiting him
Greg Spicer also was someone who was recruited by a meal to work in this area of molecular
evolution and Greg was working on
divergence of different invertebrate species using PCR which at that time was a fairly new technology
so Greg and I I would help him with some of this work go off in the Santa Cruz Mountains with
butterfly nets and collect different dragonflies and damselflies and other insects and then he
would run the DNA through the PCR and try to date the divergence of these different species
when the institute reorganized Greg was one of the new employees at IMMS so he continued to maintain
his lab and office in the building at 440 page mill road but then reported to a meal as part of IMMS
and after IMMS ended Greg took a position at San Francisco State in the department of biology
as a biology professor and I think he's still there I don't know if his time overlapped with
Krallin Krallin may have left may have retired before Greg got there but I'm sure they had friends
in common colleagues in common how would you do?
Kingdomic I did not know personally I saw him at various events and fundraisers and dinners
and so forth but I know that he was one of the three founders of the institute institute from
molecular medicine before it became known as the Linus Pauling Institute Science and Medicine
and dimic I believe was the the person who actually provided some of the funds to get the
institute off the ground in the early days there were grants transferred from Stanford but
there were also operational funds that were provided by Kingdomic and he had been instrumental
in a company that later I think was sold to variant maybe a gas chromatic chromatography
company or something like that I don't
this person named and I'm going to have another time announcing how he guessed it might be or
Alexander Alexander Nidswiki yes Alex was recruited
I believe to work with Jim Fleming in the aging program Sasagawa aging program initially
Jim was very interested in finding out the role of Hitchok proteins in longevity
life span in fruit flies primarily so he's doing a lot of work with fruit flies and also
producing transgenic fruit flies that overexpressed certain endogenous antioxidant enzymes
to try to find out if they would be more protected against toxic insult and how that would affect
their life span and things like that so Alex was working very closely with Jim
when Jim retired from the institute to go to Washington state to Spokane which is where he and his
family were from Alex started working with Matthias Rat who had then been recruited of course to
set up this cardiovascular disease laboratory at the institute so Alex began working closely with
Matthias Rat in carrying out that work she was one of the candidates that was being reviewed by
Oregon State University she didn't want to move from the Bay Area her husband was had a good job
in the Bay Area and you know as you find out many people who live in the Bay Area choose to live
there not just drawn there by their specific job but they like living there and I think
she was she certainly like living in the Bay Area and when the institute left she joined Dr.
Rat's research enterprise in Sanitarica and I believe she still works there
Fred Stitt who was someone who joined the institute in the 1980s he had worked with
Linus Pauling at Caltech I believe and it contributed to some extent on the publication of nature
of the chemical bond because I know he thanked and the acknowledgments of that book so I think he
had known Linus Pauling for a very long time I'm not quite sure what his role at Caltech was whether
he was there as a graduate student graduate fellow I don't believe he was on the faculty there but
Fred was a very very nice guy very intelligent perceptive person and he helped
organize some of the public responses for requests for information because by the mid 1980s we were
really being burdened by letters and phone calls requesting very specific information people
looking for all kinds of recommendations questions about whether they should take vitamin C or
high dose vitamin E and it had become not untenable because we felt that we were obligated to be
compassionate and as responsive as possible but Fred really helped organize responses to people so
he was trying to categorize some typical responses and then develop packets that could be sent to
people depending upon the nature of their question he did a very good job of that as well and also
responded personally to a lot of people and then he also became the newsletter editor so he worked
for at least several years editing the newsletter he would have worked closely with Cameron and
with Linus Pauline as well okay so the rest of the names that I have on my list are affiliates
rather than people who are actual employees and the first one of those is Martin Cayman. Martin
Cayman I never met Martin Cayman I know that he had a close relationship with Arthur Robinson
I don't really know much more about his involvement with the institute I believe he was on the
Board of Associates I remember correctly but I never had any interactions with him. Robert Cathcart
Robert Cathcart was a physician he died a few years ago he was what might be called an
orthomolecular physician who had gained some notoriety for developing the Cathcart prosthesis
many people who had had artificial hips implanted suffered because they didn't wear well prior
to Cathcart and Cathcart actually had the made the stunning observation that maybe we should actually
measure the actual relationship between the hip and the socket that the hip joint sits in and
from that he deduced that it was not perfectly spherical which is what most of the mechanical joints
were was more ellipsoidal so he came up with a new prosthesis that they had a much longer biological
life and he had I think he'd done some work at Stanford I don't know that he got his medical
degree at Stanford but he had been at Stanford in some capacity and then had a private practice
in incline village Nevada and had been treating people there he became very interested in Linus
Plung's work on vitamin C dating back to the 1960s and one issue that Cathcart became focused on
was how much vitamin C do you give to someone to have a therapeutic response and none of that was
known of course at the time and the transport mechanisms or the way vitamin C gets from the gastrointestinal
system into the bloodstream was not well known either people knew from simple experiments that if
you take a massive dose of vitamin C only a fraction of that gets into the bloodstream and then
a lot of it gets excreted and then a lot just passes through the gastrointestinal track and is
excreted but the reasons for all that were very vague and unclear people really didn't have much
clear idea of how vitamin C gets into the bloodstream so Cameron made the I mean Cathcart made the
observation that normal healthy people seem to be able to tolerate and it's quite variable but
can tolerate maybe a couple of grams or maybe up to five grams in a single large dose of vitamin C
before they get the laxative effect loose bowels and he observed that the same people when sick
could tolerate much much larger doses of vitamin C before that laxative effect was engaged
so he decided that that might be a good yardstick or guideline to use in the therapeutic application
of vitamin C so he recommended to his patients that take as much vitamin C as you can to reach
that bowel tolerance threshold effect of the laxative effect and then decrease slightly and continue
taking those doses of vitamin C until your symptoms are resolved and he used that pretty
successfully to treat people with flu and the common cold and other problems in his practice and
treated thousands of patients with that manner and he of course he became quite close to the
lines Pauline and I think they talked and visited each other quite often
well another very important person Erwin Stone Erwin Stone of course was about chemists who
had heard Pauline give a lecture in New York City about the merits of how Pauline wanted to live
a long time because somebody fascinating things were happening in the field of chemistry and he
really wanted to be around to get excited by all these developments in chemistry and the world
and I believe Stone followed up that with a letter to Pauline saying well there's no reason why
you should limit your expectations for a long life if you start taking vitamin C I think that you
could live another 50 years and in that letter and subsequent correspondence Stone laid out the rationale
for the belief that vitamin C might have value in promoting health span and lifespan and
decreasing the incidence of age related diseases like cancer or heart disease and
and be effective against infectious diseases and so forth so Stone had done a pretty good literature
review and he passed that along to Linus Pauline and Pauline became quite intrigued by this
correspondence with Stone and the literature that Stone referred to and he himself and his wife Ava
began taking a couple grams of vitamin C a day and made the observation that they were no longer
getting severe colds as often as they seem to get them previously so Pauline became I think convinced
that vitamin C had some value and of course this led to vitamin C in the common cold and Pauline's
own meta-analysis of the clinical literature and his own investigation of the literature on
vitamin C but I think Stone was really a catalyst for Pauline's specific interest in vitamin C.
I did meet Erwin Stone a few times he lived in San Jose had some kind of small institute in San
Jose that I think eventually was wrapped up with some help from from Rick Hicks and other people at
the institute and he came he came to see Linus Pauline periodically and I did see him at dinners
and so forth. Do you know where there's no interest in vitamin C in this regard?
The story I believe is that in a car accident he was left frail to deal with cells with vitamin C.
I think that's right I think that's exactly right. Yeah I think that's right but I don't
know why he considered vitamin C at that time. Maybe because you know if you have wounds you need
optimum collagen synthesis and vitamin C is required for collagen synthesis or you get scurvy so maybe
he just put two and two together and decided that you know for optimum healing of his wounds
both bone damage and tissue damage that vitamin C would be really important but I don't know
that for sure. I know that another fellow who reared in who was a long time friend of Linus Paulines
and very important figure in the field of orthomolecular medicine and some of the societies that grew
up around this concept of orthomolecular medicine. He was a psychiatrist by training and became very
interested in vitamin C in cancer and did a lot of clinical work in Wichita, Kansas and had a
whole center devoted to the development of high dose vitamin C oral and intravenous as a
junk to therapy for cancer. He told me that he initially became interested in vitamin C I believe
as a medical student when he had a poisonous spider bite and decided he had some irritation and some
symptoms from the spider bite and decided to just treat it with high dose vitamin C and then he
measured vitamin C content in his own urine and even after massive oral doses vitamin C content
blood I believe was extremely low so he deduced that that the vitamin C was detoxifying the spider
venom and all the sequelae from the spider bite you know inflammatory molecules and things like that
so he became convinced from his own experience again that vitamin C had some therapeutic value that
had really not been recognized by conventional physicians no he was not as a matter of fact I'm
not sure that he was even a PhD I'm not sure that he had an earned PhD it might have been an honorary
PhD but I have to check. How about Armani Hammer? Armani Hammer again was a retired physician who
had found lots of success in the business world I think one of his earliest jobs was something like
I remember correctly I hope I'm not confusing him with the other
philanthropist in New York Sackler I believe was Armani Hammer who sold pencils to Russia during
Lenin's rule made made a lot of money that way it seems like an odd way to make money but he
I'm not quite sure why he and Lenin's poem became friends but he won the or was awarded the
Linus Ponging Minitarian Award at one point and he came to visit Pauling at the institute a
number of times and I believe Pauling visited him in Southern California in a number of times that
probably at Banquets or honorary dinners and things like that so I met him and saw him a few times
but one time in the 1970s Rick Hicks had a document that needed to be signed by Armani Hammer that day
so I took a flight from San Jose to Los Angeles in the morning got a cab to Occidental Petroleum
which was headquartered in Westwood went up to see Armani Hammer chatter with him for a few
minutes got his signature brought the document back had I had something to eat in Westwood very
briefly got a cab back to LAX and flew back to San Jose and returned with a document right in time
Pauling had a relationship with Sackler too right yeah Sackler of course was another physician who
had found a lot of success in the business world and he in particular became the publisher of
Medical Tribune I think Sackler was very intrigued by Pauling's ideas in North molecular medicine
and gave Pauling quite a lot of space to write letters and articles in Medical Tribune and
really was I think he also won the Linus Pong Award for humanitarianism if my memory served me right
and he was at some of these dinners and bankwits and Pauling birthday parties and so forth
and I think Arthur Sackler once expressed Pauling the desire to help the institute in a very
substantial way but unfortunately he died before he was able to put those plans in place or
take any specific action Frederick Clinton was someone I never met I'm not sure that Linus
Pauling ever met him either but his work had been published in regional medical journals
in the southeast United States going back a blue to the 1940s and 50s and
Clinton had I think on his own started to work with very high dose vitamin C typically given
intravenously to treat all kinds of maladies including poisonous snake bites spider bites
insect bites things like that and Clinton had become convinced that this had great value
and the therapeutic response was very dramatic in many cases and he'd written lots of articles
for these regional medical journals and I think Pauling was very intrigued by his clinical work
and the anecdotes that Cleaner had about the utility of high dose vitamin C and treating different
conditions and diseases. Arthur Churkin was a PhD who had some position at the
VA hospital in Los Angeles and had worked somewhat closely with Art Robinson and Linus Pauling
perhaps in the metabolite profiling program obtaining samples or something like that
excuse me and he was on the Board of Trustees and I think served as the secretary of the Board
of Trustees for many years but I only saw him rarely. Norman Cousins was publisher of what was
it Saturday? Saturday review. It was a major American periodical who had been diagnosed with
maybe ankle mostings ankle, ankle lighting and spawned a load. I can't remember the name of the
term now but it was a nervous condition or a nerve tissue condition I believe that was sometimes
fatal and Norman Cousins became interested in Pauling's work and thought that vitamin C might
have some value so he embarked on a self-styled therapeutic regiment that included lots of laughter so
I think he watched a lot of old movies and TV shows that provided a lot of laughter and also
took very high dose vitamin C and seemed to recover very well from his illness so he in line
as Pauling became good friends. I didn't know that but it wouldn't surprise me.
Bruce Ames is someone who Pauling I think knew from Caltech when Ames was a graduate student there
Bruce Ames was friendly with his family and Peter Pauling and Linda Pauling and I'm sure had some
interactions with Linus Pauling back in those days too. Bruce became a professor of a professor in
the University of California Berkeley where he spent most of his career on the National Medal of
Science and developed very importantly something called the it's actually called the Salmonella
mutagenicity test but everybody calls it the Ames test and it's a way of using mutant bacteria
to determine the mutagenicity of certain compounds that might be present in the environment
or in the diet and also the anti-mutagenic effect of certain protective compounds or punitive
protective compounds so he's he's very highly regarded in the scientific world and he also recently
well he did work back in the 1980s on antioxidants and in particular in 1989 I believe 87 or 89
published a paper of Balte's Fry is now the director of the Linus Pi Institute showing that a
scorebait is an outstanding antioxidant in human blood so the body is full of different types of
antioxidants. Some are taken from our diet like vitamin C and vitamin E and some are synthesized
in cells in the body and provide endogenous antioxidant protection. Uric acid is another antioxidant
that can be produced in the body from dietary factors that are taken in and Balte's Fry and
Bruce Ames tried to evaluate the importance of these different antioxidants and rank them
and it turned out that vitamin C was by far and away the most powerful antioxidant in human blood
so that work of course appealed to Linus Pi and Bruce and Balte were invited to come to the
institute back in California it was the day of the Big Earthquake in 1989 and give back to back
seminars on this latest finding about vitamin C and the importance of its antioxidant
capacity in blood and Bruce has been very interested in the free radical theory of aging
and oxidative damage that might lead one to increase susceptibility to cancer for instance so
Bruce compares the free radicals that were thrown off by normal respiration and mitochondrial
activity to hits from cosmic radiation so these can very definitely damage effect and damage DNA
that could make you vulnerable to developing cancer so we've been very interested in that and how
to protect against that which includes things like antioxidants and vitamin C and then more
recently he's developed a triage theory and it's kind of extended Pauling's ideas in orthomolecular
medicine where in Pauling's original paper he talked about a couple of genetic diseases that
result in people's inability to metabolize certain dietary compounds and so forth and Bruce has
extended this to maybe 30 or more genetic diseases that can be remedied by high dose vitamin therapy
including some of the B vitamins so it's kind of a logical extension of Pauling's early ideas
in orthomolecular medicine in 2001 when we organized and convened our first diet and optimum
health conference Bruce was the first recipient of the Linus Pauling Institute Prize for Health
Research that acknowledged his pivotal and seminal work in orthomolecular medicine and worked
that you know resonates with the mission of the Linus Pauling Institute and Bruce also has been on
extramural scientific advisory board of the institute since Boltz Fry was recruited so he's
had a lot of really terrific critical feedback on the development of the institute and I think it
it could even be one of his early ideas that led to the specific development of our micronutrient
information center. Lester Packer is also a retired professor from UC Berkeley who has written
many many papers and also many books including some popular books on what he calls the antioxidant
network and Lester has been very interested in some of the more obscure antioxidants I mean he's
always been interested very much in in vitamin E in particular Marrett Traber who's one of our
principal investigators worked in Dr. Packer's lab at UC Berkeley much like Boltz Fry worked in
Bruce Haynes laboratory at UC Berkeley so they're all and also Tori Hagen who directs our
healthy aging program was working in Bruce Haynes laboratory at UC Berkeley so we have alumni
from the Ames and Packer labs Emily Ho who is one of our principal investigators also worked in the
games lab. So Lester is very interested in this concept of antioxidant network which refers to
the complex interplay between the endogenous and exogenous antioxidants in the body and how they
can collaborate and cooperate to protect us from oxidative damage so he's interested in things
like vitamin E, lapolic acid, some of the carotenoid, vitamin C, superoxid, dysmetase,
catalysts and all these other antioxidants and he's he's he's got terrific organizing skills as
well and I believe he probably played a role he may be one of the founders of the Oxygen Club
of California which holds annual meetings in California all organized to end this theme of
free radical chemistry and the effects of free radicals and antioxidants on human health and
disease. There is a very close relationship because many of our principal investigators have been
members of the Oxygen Club for a long time and we co-sponsor each other's conferences and there's
quite a lot of collaboration between the Oxygen Club of California and LPI and most recently as kind
of a manifestation of that close relationship the Oxygen Club of California donated a very nice
bronze sculpture from Christine Cunningham to the Linus Point Institute which is housed in our lobby
in the Linus Point Science Center.
So the last person on that list is Mark Levine.
Mark Levine is a physician, clinical physician and medical researcher at the National Institutes
of Health and he's had a longstanding interest in vitamin C and therapeutic application of vitamin C.
He was among the scientists at the NCI and the NIH that convened a meeting that was written
up in the pages of science as vitamin C gets a little respect and Linus Point of course participated
in that meeting, Gladys Block. He became a trustee of the Linus Point Institute of Science and Medicine.
Balsray was there, Lester Packer was there I believe.
And Jeroel and Connie Chameh attended that as well but it was a meeting organized at the NCI
to talk about the role of vitamin C in cancer and health and disease.
And Mark has carried out in recent years, well actually beginning in the mid 1990s, very
elegant, carefully controlled pharmacokinetic studies on vitamin C because he's always been
interested in how what happens to vitamin C once you take it, where does it go, how much
actually gets into the bloodstream, how does it get into the bloodstream. So he carried out some
very interesting pharmacokinetic studies that helped inform the food nutrition boards
change in 2000 of the RDAs for vitamin C. And he showed for instance that
oral vitamin C you can take as much as you want but you rarely can get above for the average person
about 200 micromole per liter concentration of vitamin C in the blood because the amount of
vitamin C that gets into the bloodstream is limited. And he didn't make these discoveries but
about a dozen years or so ago discoveries were made about the transport mechanisms,
these molecules that transport vitamin C across cells, they're on the cell surface and they
determine how much vitamin C gets into the cell. So the cells that line the epithelia around the
intestines have these transport mechanisms on them and they determine how much vitamin C gets
into the bloodstream from the intestine. And it's limited, it just doesn't diffuse through,
you know, you have a higher concentration here and a low concentration there. You might say,
well, it's just a diffusion gradient phenomenon where it diffuses from the high concentration
and the low concentration try to get equilibrium. It doesn't really work quite like that.
It may, it very, very high doses that may come into play but primarily it's controlled by these
mechanisms. And after Mark's pharmacokinetic studies with both oral vitamin C and intravenous
vitamin C, it dawned on him that, wow, maybe that explains why the male clinic studies failed
to show any benefit for high dose vitamin C because they gave vitamin C only orally whereas
Cameron typically gave vitamin C intravenously and orally. And when you give it intravenously you
bypass these control mechanisms on cells and you can get very, very high concentrations in the
blood that depending on the dose can be 70 or 100 times greater, millimole concentrations of
vitamin C in the blood that are unobtainable by oral vitamin C. And Mark has since gone on to
show in a series of really great experiments, cell culture experiments and small animal experiments
that these very high concentrations of vitamin C generate hydrogen peroxide in the milieu
around tumor cells. And then the hydrogen peroxide can presumably diffuse into the tumor cells
and cause their death by different mechanisms, including interfering with mitochondrial machinery
and causing atop poses, apoptosis, sorry. So where does this line of research just want to
do you do your trials? Yeah, the line of research is so engaging and now that we have a better
mechanistic understanding of vitamin C in cancer and we have a better understanding of the pharmacokinetics
this is led to a number of preliminary clinical trials phase one clinical trials and be followed
up by other clinical trials. I'm sure that we'll get at these issues of safety, combination with
other standard drug therapy because there's some evidence that some of the arsenic compounds that
are used chemotherapeutically are potentiated by vitamin C which also tends to decrease the side
effects of the arsenic trioxide compounds. So lots of questions remain, optimum dose of vitamin C,
the frequency of vitamin C, slow drip infusion versus periodic injection a few times a week.
All those questions really need to be answered and those issues need to be characterized much
more carefully and we really don't at this point have any predictive ability so we don't know which
people would which cancer patients are going to benefit most from high dose vitamin C.
Clearly it's not a panacea for all cases of terminal cancer and there are many people that
have not benefited from high dose IV vitamin C and that needs to be understood as well.
And interestingly this all harps back to work that Pauline published with Japanese researchers
back in the 80s showing that vitamin C can generate hydrogen peroxide and cell culture experiments
and that this is what's killing tumor cells. So back in the 1980s as I said earlier that's when
Pauline's attention started to focus more on the cytotoxicity of vitamin C and degradation
products of vitamin C direct effects against cancer cells as opposed to humoral effects with host
resistance. So I think it's very promising a lot needs to be learned. The patient population in
Scotland may be quite different from the contemporary patient population in the United States and
you know all these it's very very complex and there are a lot of issues that need to be
really analyzed and thought about very carefully but I think the upshot is that
many complementary so-called complementary physicians are now using high dose IV vitamin C
as a junked of cancer therapy but we don't yet have good data acquisition and analysis
of all those anecdotal reports and I think you know people are interested in getting that information.
Well so there might be some validation after Pauline's attention for 35-40 years later.
I think there will be validation for Pauline and Kermann and interestingly enough
if you if you look carefully in some of Pauline's writings particularly
after the male clinic trials I mean he and Kermann and others came up with
criticisms of the male clinic methodology and there were lots of criticisms that were
fine criticisms. The fact that the patients have undergone parochymotherapy in the first trial
or vitamin C was suspended in the second trial and then patients started to die when the
vitamin C was stopped abruptly and there seemed to be fairly high concentrations of vitamin C in the
urine of some of the placebo patients which makes people doubt that they were true placebo patients.
So they had a lot of criticism about the methodology but at least Pauline and I believe Kermann
also noted in print that there was a big difference between the mode of administration
and although they didn't have evidence at the time to suggest that
IV vitamin C was definitely more effective Pauline
speculated that this may have some importance so I think he was very insightful there as well.
Well
yeah I'd have to finish unpacking my office and look at some of the early
employment rosters to see if there were there people there. I mean I knew a lot of people
over a long period of time and I think we've touched on most of the principles but clearly there
were a lot of other people that worked there because there were I mean you know there were 75 or
80 people working at the institute at different times so ed blazedel is another one who worked
with a lot of data analysis Steve Burbek is another person who maybe I should talk about this
for just a moment I don't know if Steve Burbek was on your list there. Steve Burbek was I think had
research experience in audiology or psychology and hearing or something like that but also had
strong background in computer science when we were developing this program of protein profiling
and just to give you a brief introduction to that if you're interested in finding out what
differences in gene activity or proteins might be between one type of cell and another say a normal
cell in a cancer cell you need some way to to quantify or visualize those proteins and one
way of doing that is to have different cell populations that you're growing in petri dishes
and say for sake of example you have a population of normal cells in one petri dish and a
population of those normal cells that have been treated with something to make them tumorogenic
in a different dish then you can incubate those cells with something like S35 methionine which
is a radioactive isotope of sulfur combined with methionine which is an amino acid that gets incorporated
into proteins so as these cells in the dish are making new proteins and growing they're
incorporating this radioactive methionine because you're growing them in a normal methionine deficient
medium and you replace the normal methionine with this radioactive methionine so now all the proteins
that incorporate methionine in these cells now become radioactive so at the end of a certain
period of time you can drain the fluid from these cells you can collect all the cells you can
rupture them which is called cell lysis and then you end up with a little radioactive cell lysate
and you can separate the proteins in that cell lysate and has to be treated in certain ways
in these porous polyacrylamide gels on the basis of their
isoelectric point which is related to a pH gradient and also on the basis of the molecular weight
so you do a two-dimensional separation of these proteins under the influence of an electric
field and you end up with a rectangular gel about half the size of a piece of stationary paper
and that gel can be dried onto a piece of filter paper so now you've got this gel that contains
all these radioactive proteins dried onto a piece of filter paper you can put that up against
a piece of film and put it in a film cassette in the dark for x number of hours or days then you
take the film out and you develop it in the film processor and if you look at the film you'll see
hundreds or thousands of little spots that correspond to a radioactive emission from the
methining residue on the proteins so then you can the question is well how do you quantify that
so you've got all these spots of varying intensity and size all over this piece of film
so part of Steve Burbeck's program at the institute Jerry Ladder participated in this
and other people participated in it as well was to develop hardware and software that would
help us and now analyze these films and come up with quantitative information so we bought for
instance a drum scanner and a drum scanner is simply a device on which you can mount one of these
films and then it spins around really fast and it digitizes these spots so now you've got
information in the computer about the position and intensity and size of these spots and you
can use that to create a pseudo image on a computer screen that corresponds to the you know the
position of all these images in the computer screen correspond to the spots that you saw in the
x-ray film exactly the same only now they can be color coded for intensity and Steve Burbeck and
Jerry Ladder and others develop software programs that allowed us to to analyze these images very
carefully and come up with quantitative information so we could find out whether certain proteins were
decreasing in synthesis or increasing in synthesis in these tumor cells or whether new proteins were
being synthesized or whether certain proteins being synthesized in the normal cells were suddenly
disappearing in the tumor cells and to do that kind of analysis in a quantitative way is really
complicated and Steve Burbeck and Jerry Ladder and others worked on for years on a program to help
us analyze those gels that developed all kinds of really sophisticated algorithms to help us
understand and match so we had a semi-automated system that would allow us to match spots
from one gel to another so if you have an image for the normal cell proteins and then an image
side by side on the computer screen from the tumor cell proteins you want to be able to match
one protein from one image to the same protein and the other image and to do that you need very
sophisticated software so they spend quite a number of years developing software to help us in
that kind of analysis so it was a big program actually at the institute
not offhand